Piers Morgan right get gets brought up a
few times throughout the book is it
coincidental or does he just happen to
embroider himself in these situations a
lot what the [ __ ] going on with Piers
Morgan that surveillancing point I
actually saw Piers Morgan this morning
his morning show and he his wife wrote a
very nice column mentioning my book the
other day and I thought okay she's read
it I wonder if he has because yet the
reference is Tim are not that obliging
and unfortunate this morning I went with
a copy of the book and at the end of the
show just we finished recording piers
said is that one great spur Douglas I
said yeah can I have it that's it yeah
no of course
and I thought well maybe I should have
taken that page out but never thee no
but he M yeah he's actually coincidence
in a way because I mean he's off you
whether one agrees or disagrees or likes
or dislikes or whatever I mean he's
definitely one of those characters who
throws himself into things in his case
we're just you know Glee but it doesn't
mean sometimes that people like that are
sometimes there at interesting cultural
turning point moments and I think to the
to K times he comes up in the book I
don't anyone viewing this to think this
is like a biography of Piers Morgan no
it's I can I can assure that he isn't
but the two times he comes up it's
because yeah he's sort of he's thrown
himself right into the middle of a
culture war and something happened as a
consequence and and if he's interesting
there are figures sort of slight
lightning rods for good and he'll who
you notice yeah crop up but I I'm one
things I'm proud of about this book is
that I try to do everything from looking
at the philosophy and deep ideas that
cause some things we're going through
right up to you know what happened on
the view or good morning Britain
yesterday because it's quite easy for
people who love books as I do to think
books create the world or you know
massively influenced or maybe they do
have an influence but so does television
service pop music so does so as wraps
that is twitter twitter and and really
the the interesting challenge which I
hope I've managed to rise my two
occasion of was to try to encompass all
of that say you know this is the era we
are in and this is the madness we are
going through and to do that on
everything from the level of the deep
deep ideas all the way through to these
television events for instance which
have a massive impact on the culture you
know if somebody is destroyed live on
air mm-hmm for not saying the thing that
nobody said till yesterday everyone
learns everyone
[Music]
you